this video was made possible by class
central.com / Pakman which lets you
watch tens of thousands of lectures from
the world's best universities check it
out by clicking the link underneath the
video this episode of the pseudo-science
mini series is about psychics a psychic
claims to have extrasensory perception
ESP the ability to receive information
through means other than the five
recognized physical senses clairvoyance
seeing the future or past talking to
dead people are examples I actually
covered ESP in a previous episode of the
mini series in this video we'll talk
about the actual techniques that
psychics use to fool people for about 90
years science has tested supernatural
claims by psychics and we have no proof
that it actually exists the scientific
consensus remains that there is no
evidence that psychics have supernatural
powers so let's jump right into it
sometimes psychics do background
research about their subject either
themselves or through a third party in
some cases this is preparing for what's
called a hot reading in a hot reading
the psychic has collected information
about their subject in advance and often
psychics will read their subjects on the
spot without knowing them or any
detailed information about them and
that's called cold reading and that's
about sizing up your subject and using
techniques to increase the probability
that you'll say things that seem
accurate people often don't realize how
much information you can infer just from
seeing someone noticing their behavior
even just talking for a few minutes and
before a cold reading a psychic can tell
a lot from physical appearance age
gender ethnicity body language the way
someone talks and dresses their hair
these things and others are important
clues about a person and things that are
probably happening in that person's life
that's the first step for a psychic
during a cold reading and knowing how to
use those Clues is a big part of it the
rest is a game of probability when a
psychic is cold reading an audience
they'll do what's called shotgunning
throwing out vague ideas
hoping something sticks and that
somebody will say yeah that's that's me
the psychic might say I'm sensing that
someone has lost a loved one or someone
is struggling with their health or
having money problems and if you've got
a big enough crowd it's a common or
general enough prediction it probably
ensures that the psychic seems
successful now when working one-on-one
psychics benefit from using what are
known as Barnum statements which could
apply to almost anyone examples would be
sometimes you're too critical of
yourself you don't live up to your true
potential in a certain aspect of your
life you can find it sometimes to be
unwise to tell people too much about
yourself almost anybody would relate to
these statements but in the heat of the
moment during a reading it's easy to be
tricked into thinking that the psychic
actually knows something about you
individually there's a variation of
Barnum statements called the rainbow
ruse and that's a statement that
attributes a personality trait to
someone but also attributes the opposite
okay so a couple of examples would be
you're a driven person
but you sometimes succumb to laziness
well yeah that applies to most people
right because it's a and the opposite of
a you like to be the life of the party
but sometimes you feel more reserved
these are often interpreted as accurate
because not only is the trait relatable
to almost anybody the psychic also
assigns the opposite of the trait and
all bases are covered
everybody has conflicting traits or
traits that manifest sometimes but not
all the time
psychics also like to pretend they know
the names of people in your life someone
that died or someone you broke up with
when psychics make guesses about names
they usually use common names or lists
the series of names or even the first
letter of a name until they get a hit
and psychics can narrow it down by using
common names to the demographic of the
subject like age or ethnicity I'm
sensing that you care very much about
someone whose name starts with s this
increases the odds because it's less
specific and it allows the psychic to
say they were talking about the first
name or maybe it was the last name a
really common one is
I'm getting a J or a G sound this is two
different letters and according to the
Social Security Administration 38 of the
most popular 200 names in the u.s. from
the last hundred years start with either
J or G combine that with other vague
criteria like it's someone in your
family or someone you work with and it
is very likely that the psychic gets a
hit when predicting or reading causes of
death
psychics usually stick to common causes
of death in the u.s. these are heart
disease cancer accidents and strokes if
a psychic says I'm sensing that you know
someone who has died of cancer there's a
good chance they're going to be right
even knowing someone alive with cancer
could appear to be a hit even though the
person is still alive and not dead or
the psychic could be even more vague and
say I'm sensing you know someone who had
a heart problem or issues with their
lungs it's definitely something related
to the chest
how many conditions could that apply to
sometimes the psychic will start
specific see if there's a hit and get
more vague until they get a hit or they
can say that what they're talking about
is actually just a metaphor for
something else and vagueness always
plays in their favor are you having
problems with your neck no what about
your head headaches right now maybe it's
something with the head of your company
did you get a new boss at work oh you
did get a new boss well the head is a
symbol for boss in this particular case
keep in mind when you're dealing with
someone who has already paid to consult
a psychic they want the psychics powers
to be real powers when a psychic keeps
missing the mark or someone refuses to
play along they'll often say well you
just don't yet realize that I'm right or
this is something you should look into
or you've got to be on the lookout for
or you'll later remember how this
relates psychics actually depend on the
subject to do most of the work because
when we're interacting with someone we
give all sorts of clues we're not aware
of what our eyes do how we hold our arms
or our posture and psychics are good at
responding to these
in real time if someone nods or looks
intrigued the psychic will stop talking
and allow the person to fill in the
blanks with information if the subject
looks confused
the psychic will rattle off more ideas
until something sticks
this makes the missus less obvious and
the subject might forget that there were
misses at all cold reading is a very
intricate technique and psychics can be
extremely good with practice there's
more to cold reading than I can cover in
this video but that's why it's so
powerfully deceptive because most people
don't fully understand how it actually
works and its power check out the
example of Theresa Caputo she has a
reality show on TLC called Long Island
medium she's one of the most well-known
psychics right now she claims to talk to
the dead and she charges people hundreds
of dollars to come to her live events
when she's on tour he also wants me to
tell you cuz I felt the restriction
again he says I want you to know that
before I hit that water I was already
gone do you understand that he says
everyone says that I drowned he says I
want them to know that I didn't suffer
he says Theresa everything happened so
quickly it was like boom boom boom
psychics who say they talk to the dead
are usually dealing with emotionally
vulnerable subjects they want closure or
insight about the person they lost and
usually it's someone who already
believes in psychic abilities to begin
with so they want it to work they
believe it can work the subject can be
too distracted or emotionally
defenseless to recognize the tricks and
this combined with psychics having good
cold reading skills means a perfect
formula for creating situations where
the subject is willing to go along with
whatever the psychic says in this clip
remember that the woman being read is
someone who wants to participate and
believes in the psychic powers of
Theresa Caputo if your mother isn't a
party it could be your grandmother
mother-in-law
maybe it's your mother who has died or
another woman in your family she's
talking to a woman who appears to be
about 45 years old
chances are pretty good that she has a
mother grandmother or mother-in-law who
has died where does the mother come in
where does the mother figure come in I
know that's not who you want yeah no my
mother's still with me back that's right
I know that so my grandmother come in if
the woman being read had said yes it's
my mom who died the psychic could have
said yeah see exactly I'm psychic but
that was a no so now we're changing it
to mother figure Oh your mom is still
alive well yeah no I knew that I'm
talking about your grandmother or a
mother figure or maybe Mother Earth as a
symbol for Humanity or maybe it's mother
Goose I mean at this point who knows I
don't care if it's an aunt that was like
a mother to you okay okay it has to be
someone of that nature but she talks
about jewelry so I don't know if you
have her jewelry or there was something
that you were supposed to inherit or and
or have another miss Theresa is then
told that it was actually the woman's
father who died so Theresa tries to say
okay your father saw your kids receive
an award or graduate from school you
have children yes it was it just
something with you children because he
just brought me to when they bring me to
an elementary school they put me on a
stage it's just my symbol for where
someone either received an award or they
was just a graduation well he no he
never got to meet my kids
oh he died oh he never met your kids
okay perfect that's exactly what I meant
then she says is the number three
relevant to you at all how do you
connect with the number three you have
three children I have well I have two
children I guess Karen no I didn't have
a miscarriage but I hear she says no I
didn't have a miscarriage and Theresa
Caputo goes mmm I guess suggesting to
this woman that yes maybe you did have a
miscarriage but you didn't know it just
so that her psychic vision will seem
accurate unbelievable here's Theresa
Caputo on Anderson Cooper's old daytime
talk show this is a really good example
of the shotgunning technique
throwing out a bunch of ideas in a large
room of people and hoping that there is
a match somebody lost a spouse newly and
someone also lost a sister and someone
is also wearing the mother or
grandmothers religious articles whether
if it's like a miraculous metal across
rosary beads or they brought them with
them there seem to be hundreds of people
in this room many are most of whom are
at least middle-aged chances are pretty
good that somebody in the room has lost
a spouse or sister or is wearing a
family member's religious jewelry who
lost the spouse I think I'm right I'm
right here is your wife departed your
wife is departed okay cuz she just she
said next see what she said just sit
down just sit down would that be her
personality to say just you know maybe
don't don't speak up yet quite so much
is that her wedding ring my mother's
which all cuz I heard some the wedding
ring and your that's your mom's wedding
ring yes it is this is my wife's wedding
ring here oh you have the wedding ring
but where is the chair why do I keep
getting the thing with the chair do you
still have her chair no or did she have
an issue with her legs prior to her
passing no she had a swing and a Miss
okay that guy wasn't working out so well
so I'm going to ask a roomful of 200
people if they know something about legs
and move on what the issue with the legs
paralyzed or something amputated was
there an issue with the legs where your
husband was his bed restriction is that
correct what was with his legs she well
she shade that point is she's shaking
her head no so that's fine look you
don't have to acknowledge it I don't
care
Wow and then she basically tells this
woman that she's a liar because she
denied having lost someone who had
problems with their legs I don't care if
he believed in what I do that's not what
they just accept that yeah I'm sorry
you're afraid what about me I'm talking
to dead people
[Applause]
Caputo is great about using humor to
lighten the mood and connect with the
subjects and distract them psychics who
talked to the dead are especially vile
because they exploit profound sadness it
makes the subject more agreeable it
gives them a false way of dealing with
their grief and there's always the
question do psychics know that what
they're doing is BS with some psychics
we could give them the benefit of the
doubt some psychics probably do think
that they have special powers you can be
an expert cold reader and have no idea
that that's what you're actually doing
you have lots of practice you've gotten
great at it but you have no idea because
you continue to improve at cold reading
recognizing cues people give an
understanding probability and you seem
to be a psychic but there are many
psychics who do know that they're frauds
and once you've realized how easy it is
to make money doing it maybe it's
difficult to stop it is how they make a
living after all and many psychics like
Theresa Caputo rationalize what they're
doing they justify it in moral terms
they say it doesn't matter if you
believe it's real because it gives
people a way to deal with the loss of a
loved one or a way to be introspective
about their problems and of course
whether it's helping anyone has nothing
to do with whether it's real bottom line
psychics aren't the people to rely on to
help solve your problems psychics can't
tell you anything about your life that
you don't already know maybe you'd be
better off seeing a doctor or a
therapist an accountant or a lawyer even
to solve problems that you're actually
facing in the real world
someone with an expertise that's based
in reality
psychic practice is pseudoscience but if
you want to learn something new and
fascinating about a real scientific
topic a great place to start is class
central.com / pakman class central lets
you take entire college courses online
from top universities including Harvard
MIT Stanford and Berkeley whether you're
interested inside
politics philosophy psychology there are
tens of thousands of courses to choose
from on basically any topic imaginable
and many are completely free check it
out click the link in the description
search for a class on a topic that
interests you that is class
- central.com slash PA que ma n